what is up everybody welcome to another
Raspberry Pi tutorial in this tutorial
we're gonna be doing one last thing
before we get into just some basic
terminal commands and what we're gonna
be doing is talking about how to update
your firmware and the reason you want to
update your firmware is they actually
well first of all they update the
firmware in like all the time just like
every few days pretty much and also when
they update the firmware you get all
kinds of new things and if you've ever
like hacked around with any sort of
product over the years you've probably
learned that sometimes you actually
might want to revert back to an older
firmware version etc so it's always good
to to know how to how to do that and
actually the process to do that is
really simple with the Raspberry Pi so
anyway with that we'll go ahead and just
hop right on into that the first thing
you'll want to do is open up your
terminal and you should notice that your
terminal opens quite a bit faster than
it has before if you are indeed
overclock so congratulations on not
having to wait so much with your pod and
really my PI is not too hot I mean it's
hotter than it was initially but it's
not too bad I wonder if they're
eventually I should look up you know
like your computers have a program
called real temp and it's really useful
for monitoring your temperatures so I
wonder if there's something similar for
the PI that we could put on there if not
real temp anyways it's anything on the
first thing that we want to do is we
need to make sure our firmware is up to
date now my firmware since my PI is a
relatively new PI I'm gonna venture to
guess my firmware is indeed up to date
but yours might not be so suppose that I
will attempt to help you guys out so the
first thing that you want to do is pull
a download our PI update because that's
what will help you download your your
firmware so to get that we're going to
do sudo apt - get so that's gonna
install stuff probably like the most
awesome thing in the world
it comes to using like Linux is when you
just you need to download and install
something it's like one line in your in
your terminal and it does everything
it's so much easier did like download
and install programs anyway what we want
to get is RPI update so hit enter and I
guess we'll wait for to build some trees
awesome and as you can see RPI update is
already the newest version so we've got
that now to get the latest version of
the firmware what you want to do is go
to it is the github for RPI firmware I
think what I'll just do is just put the
link in the description this time and
what you want to do is you want to look
at the commits and you want to take the
shock code or the hash code basically
for the latest version in my case the
latest version was three days ago so
I'll go ahead and actually try to grab
that and let me see here if I can just
copy and paste it in for anybody who is
watching this right with me now go over
into our leafpad open that up and let me
see if I can copy and paste right into
it no I wasn't able to but you'll just
have to take my word for it and I'll
leave it up on screen when we're done so
the next thing that we want to do is we
want to actually update to this newest
firmware since it was so recently I bet
I don't have the most recent firmware it
looks like just by looking at this page
like they're updating the firmware like
every three to seven days anyway
continuing on let me drive let's alright
so what we want to do to put the or to
update we're gonna do sudo and then RPI
and our sudo our IP sudo RPI - update
there's no space that I don't think
because you're specifying like what it
is is you're dating your nevermind but
anyway it's it's like a
jool basically so now what we want to
update to is gonna be the following I'll
just try to type it out slowly but also
I'll pause the videos so you guys could
just like copy and paste so it is going
to be 9 5 6 0 8 B 0 0 7 fe 5 a 5 a a a B
5 B C 1 3 0 3 5 c c e 9 4 c f9 c 0 e 6 5
b ok hopefully we didn't type of this
because that's really a pain in the
focus performing the update and we wait
and we we do this awesome and you like
download all these updates and they
install and like guy you can't do this
on windows anyway check out this awesome
loading bar thing like pretty epic like
the guy that coded this is probably just
so proud of himself you know how woody
was so proud of myself you know and when
you are finally done you will be here
now again if you're watching this video
later than like 7 days since I posted it
then chances are there's a newer
firmware and again I really try my
hardest to remember to put this link in
the description I forget to put the
links in the description all the time so
yeah so that's pretty much it with the
installation of first of all the RPI
update but then also updating or you
could use the exact same process to
downgrade your raspberry PI's firmware
as always thank you for watching thank
you for your support your subscriptions
and until next time